The Android M release is coming.
And Android developers
across the globe
are busy testing their apps
against the developer preview.
If you've not joined
them yet, then now
is the perfect opportunity.
I'm Rich Hyndman, and this is a
quick guide to the M Developer
Preview, the core features
you should be testing,
and a couple of new
APIs to look out
for, along with how to
provide feedback to us.
Let's jump right in.
The M Developer Preview consists
of SDK tools, emulators,
device images, documentation,
and sample code,
and you can get it all from
developer.android.com/preview.
If you're anything
like me, you're
going to want to get a device
image up and running first.
So if you've got a Nexus
5, 6, 9, or Nexus player,
you probably followed the
link to the Downloads page
already and got
your device image.
Stop.
I wish we could dive
straight into that,
but if you're not running the
preview version of the SDK
Tools, you may run into a
missing system.img error.
So let's get the SDK first.
If you don't already have
Android Studio installed
or would like a separate
instance for the preview,
then go to
developer.android.com/sdk
to download the current version.
Then you're going to open up
the Preferences or Settings
depending on your OS.
Go to Appearance and Behavior,
System Settings, and Updates.
Switch it over to check
for studio updates
from the Canary Channel and
SDK updates from the Preview
Channel, hit Check Now,
and wait for the magic.
Android Studio is going
to update and restart,
then you can head
back into Settings
and you'll be able to
update to the new SDK
platform, and the all
important Preview SDK Tools.
Also, at the same time pick
up the new support repository.
And you're all ready to go.
If you're starting
a new project,
you can now choose
Target SDK M Preview.
Otherwise, update
your grade or build
files to use Android MNC as
your compile SDK version.
You could also head into the AVD
manager and set up an emulator.
Select a device of your
choice, and use the MNC x86
image for the best performance.
And finally we can get back
to flashing our devices.
So now ensure your
data's backed up,
and follow the steps
in the preview guide.
If your boot loader's
locked, then you're
going to have to unlock it
first, which means on a Nexus 6
or Nexus 9 first checking
in the developer options
that OEM unlocking is enabled.
Then use ADB to reboot
into boot loader,
run fast boot OEM unlock,
and get your system images,
and execute the
flash-all script.
To be secure, it's
recommended once
that's done to lock
your boot loader again.
It should be smooth sailing,
and if you do hit that missing
system.img error,
then double check
you're definitely using
the latest [? fast boot ?]
from the Preview SDK Tools.
Now, you have an Android M
Preview device or emulator
ready for testing.
As always with new releases, we
have some changes in behavior
that we recommend you test out.
So please head straight over
to the Behavior Changes page.
First and foremost, it's the
new runtime permissions model.
Runtime permissions are here.
They provide less friction
on install and automatic app
updates.
But you can no longer
assume that just
because your app's installed,
it has all the stated
permissions granted.
Permissions are now
granted at run time
and users can also
revoke permissions
on a per app basis at any
time, even for legacy apps.
For testing, we have all new
ADB commands and parameters
for granting and
revoking permissions.
So check out the permissions
guide on the preview
site for details.
Always check that
you have a permission
before trying to use it, and
if you don't, request it.
If there's a set of permissions
that your app needs,
like camera access
for a camera app,
then it can be worth requesting
them upfront in a warm welcome.
Next, Android Auto Backup.
This is a new service
designed to simplify
building a robust
data backup service
and to improve the
lives of users.
Up to 25 megabytes of data
is backed up per application,
and you can watch Matthew's
video for full details.
If your project
targets [? M, ?] then
backup's going to be
automatically enabled,
and there are a couple of
things you should be aware of.
If you have any data you
don't want backed up,
like device specific
or encrypted data,
then you can move it into the
Get No Backup Files directory.
You can now also specify
an inclusive or exclusive
backup scheme or potentially
opt out of backup all together.
For testing, there are new ADB
shell backup manager commands.
And in the M Preview
Build, auto backup
is enabled for all applications.
For the actual final
M release, we're
only going to do it for apps
that target M or higher.
It's also worth mentioning that
for testing the new fingerprint
APIs, we've added a new
ADB finger touch command,
and that's going to
simulate fingerprint input.
Check out the preview site and
Maya's video for full details.
Finally, some good news, this
year we'll be making updates
to the SDK and device images
throughout the preview,
so join the developer
preview community
on +AndroidDevelopers, and you
only need to flash your device
once, as once you've flashed the
[? dev ?] preview system image,
it's going to automatically
be upgraded over the year.
So please, do check out the
preview for other features
like doze, app standby,
adoptable storage,
data binding, and the
very powerful app linking.
Test early.
Join the Android M
Developer Community.
File bugs in the issue tracker.
Enjoy another tasty treat.